happy new year's eve reject nation
thank you so much everyone has been a
part of this channel for such a
long ass time hope you got a great
resolution in mind
i think this is the last video we're
uploading this year i think yeah i'm
pretty sure it is so i decided that
today we should check out
from a channel we love we've seen many
of this channel's videos before
mighty raccoon peter parker versus
miles morales spider-man battle
marvels spider-man alternative fight a
lot of great keywords in there
anywho talked so much about spider-man
the last month and a half what a great
way to end off the month
love the video game miles morales let's
see who wins
i have a feeling it's gonna be miles
that's just my prediction
just my prediction i think it'll be a
draw
[Music]
just try to keep up
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
oh so they're like straight out from the
video game is this one
at least those models yeah the
interpretation i'm getting
please say no please say no
wait what
hey hey um sorry i'm late now
oh no no i'm just glad you're here all
right so
[Music]
all right we'll call the play coach okay
okay all right put them up
seriously okay
[Music]
oh shoot
rise on the occasion
nice
no no
it's all good
ready
[Music]
just try to keep
[Music]
cool cool cool
[Music]
[Applause]
pretty amazing
damn miles is showing him up
[Music]
how's it hmm especially i'm backlit like
that
one with the new model
[Music]
so when does the fight start again
oh no peter
i don't like it
[Music]
[Music]
god no height even
no who do i want to win
[Music]
oh cool
now make out that was something lesson's
over
gotta go oh
no there we go baby there we go baby
[Music]
i like the sound of that
there better be a direct sequel to this
there better be a direct sequel where
they fight venom
props to the animators
yes do yourself a favor like share
subscribe
my raccoons video yeah that was awesome
that was wonderful that was awesome
they're very impressive
i mean i played the miles morose game i
think a month ago so listening to this
there were times where i i couldn't tell
if you just took
audio samples from the dialogue itself
from cut scenes
within the video game and just place
them here because there were times with
the audio switching where it would sound
that way
i didn't see anything unless i missed it
and i didn't see anything about credited
voice over actors either way it blended
naturally whether it's voice over actors
or if you did take audio directly and
you know other than the mighty raccoon
animation
style this easily could have been a
sequence from the video game itself
considering the mentorship that peter
has and then with where the game
ends off i won't ruin it for anyone who
hasn't played but with where the game
ends off and with the point where miles
is at
i feel like this could easily be a
continuation of what happened there
especially getting venom in there like
with the better punch and then having
venom in there and then the black
symbiotic oh
yeah so i'm talking about mighty raccoon
you know what's funny about the journey
with watching this video is before going
into this
was expecting miles to win i was
expecting him to win and i wanted him to
know when to
because i'm like well peter has more
experience he's the mentor
it would just be more of the underdog
tail if miles ended up winning and then
when this fight starts
miles is owning his [ __ ] i feel like
my house is
miles was predominantly winning through
mostly even after peter got the
black suit on he was still for the most
part
you know holding his own peter landed a
few good punches in there
but that's what i thought was really
fascinating about watching this was oh
i want peter to win now i'm always going
for the underdog you know so when peter
was starting to lose him like maybe i
maybe want peter to put him back in his
place but
i'm not kind of confused what you wish
for i guess
uh i don't know what no one really came
out of winter there doomsday showed up
at the end and they just teamed up
with you i was with you well we both got
to deal with this now
yeah no this was super fun and uh hats
off to your animators because i was
noticing like beyond just the look of
the characters yeah looking ripped
straight out of the game just the
quality of the lights and the focal
lengths you guys were using and the
shadows and whatnot like it's funny when
peter makes that crack about feeling
like he's in a horror movie then you cut
to miles and he's like backlit in the
shadows
it's like it's not even that sinister
but it still reads that way so like you
brought
so much visual personality through an
already well
rapport between these two characters and
yeah this took on life of its own as
something where i'm like did you just
use skins and create like your own cut
scene or like it really makes me curious
as to what level
of animation you guys are traveling
under because this was so smooth to me
yeah i mean you had the comedic horror
touch with the fact that everywhere he
turns miles is somehow getting the upper
hand on him or he's ahead of him or he's
next to him or he's there
already you know so i loved having those
elements
and uh yeah i mean bringing the city to
life too like i said it feels like it
could have been a post-credits scene in
spider-man miles morales
i loved it i loved it mighty raccoon
whenever your video yours comes out it's
always exciting because
we don't get like them all the time but
whenever we get them
it's always a treat there's a lot of tlc
put into it anyway
i'm ready for 2020 to end how about you
guys
one more week let's extend this year
yeah let's postpone it they didn't
ratify 2021 yet so who knows
my goodness that's what peter was
putting on him the vaccine right there
in that moment right
i'm probably immune for a few weeks
guys subscribe to my raccoon if you
haven't done so already subscribe to the
real rejects click that like button
hey i'll see you in the new year or
later today if something else comes out
that must be covered right away
[Music]
bye
[Music]
you